elle est avec moi cette année alors
soprano venez la honda comment on a des
cartes nous avez ici vauvert ça veut
dire que si vous perdez la première
bataille taxer pour vous attention si on
a la même carte signa bataille on peut
prendre n'importe lequel
d'accord sur celui qui gagne mais est ce
qu'on va crescendo ça veut dire quoi
exactement
on va le dire n'ont pas le droit de
commencer par sa mort ah bah non sinon
et il ya des cartes aux bonus votre et
nabila ou enora d'accord ça veut dire
nous remplacer un bambin battons notre
pratique alors attention vous voulez
coupé jeu coupal et j'ai coupé parce que
comme ça vous allez voir il n'y a pas de
tri ya pas de triche
attention c'est parti on va démarrer un
fonctionnaire là bas d'accord mais j'ai
l'impression que ça triste rennoncer
bonheur des mois de faire attention
vous voulez démarrer voulait prendre la
première carte nous apprend aussi
comment aller je commence attention y'a
pas une petite musique d'ambiance dame
de coeur
j'ai pas mal je suis pas mal
heureusement et des serviettes et elle
serait on a une bonne petite production
allez-y soprano devra être le betis here
on est débouté dépouillé déboutonnée au
maire doit vraiment y déjà ah bah oui
bah oui c'est ça attends attends je ne
sais pas s'il va pleuvoir fait de voir
ça il ya et le set de piques alalala
l'avons sopra non bon se promener la
forme elle s'habille verse à la lutte
ouvert c'est après ce que vous voulez
démarrer sur la prochaine où je démarre
c'est moi qui l'ait mardi l'accord
allait y aller
attention démarrer faut faire savoir dès
sein du scot le rsa va là je sais après
je sais je connais après ça fait comme
une petite raie artificielle ces
problématiques sa stature us ou bon au
moins tout le monde sait que c'est pas
moi qui ai alors vous inquiétez pas
c'est ça allez-y sopra soprano le cette
encore le 7 sept docteurs je peux faire
moi je comprends le verbe le roi
il n'y a pas de ces boîtes à sata pour
me réchauffer je fais quelques ponts
adacore allez-y c'est vous
alors ça y est les shows attention
attention tu veux
bon c'est pas moi aussi moi si je perds
rares moments
moi je compense tout pour parce qu'on
joue faut pas salir on joue on en est
vraiment dans une petite dernière
non je peux dire et redire mais ferry la
boule à thé un bon attaquant mais mois
de mai je connais pas les cartes du vous
jure sauvera et vous voulez dire en
premier ou ce tir en premier ben vas-y
je tiens à quoi vous j'ai dis je au
joker et nohra
quand on sera donc et nous raconterons
cette injustice mais moi je lui mettrai
jamais dit à abc si laval ont aussi tiré
la carte
peut-être que peut-être que vous avez la
carte était désiré la carte que c'est
l'habit la haye un nas et narrativement
c'est la famille je rêve a bien vas-y ah
non je tire une carte le roi en plus il
était pas mal mais je ne peux pas vous
pouvez pas fait très chaud à écouter
tout petit vous voulez un tout petit bb
à bb et bb- allez-y alors tu es prêt
azim jeune homme était devant ou
derrière drogba s'il vous plaît
et
ne manquez pas ce que je vais l'enlever
devant ou détention alors exactement je
préfère de moyens plus de matière elle
préfère monsieur non et je le connais
parce qu'après ça va dit je connais moi
là le corps une attention c'est la
dernière
l'an dernier elle aurait cependant
attentif aux risques et sony sony
seraient inquiètes ont fait la dernière
pour suivre l on suit la course et nous
n'avons celui là c'est parti bonne
chance est ce que vous voulez que je
tire ou vous tiré en premier
je tiens la route irish la chorale isme
à l'est la force qua non c'est non non
on est pas trop que je dois rentrer je
prends le tgv mais vous êtes parent dont
ils nous avaient une chance de les gars
c'est un trip 2 8
attention bataille on la refait
les autres
bataille attaché au sommet les créatures
en première ou la tirer de cette phase
est un roi
non non c'est ce côté ce ne tienne le
côté aménagé réaménage actionnaires
non mais j'ai cliqué quelque chose dans
la bataille à la carte qui roucoule
d'accord soit le sahara calaisis livre
de cinq à dix on sait jamais ah oui
vraiment je prends
ça
vous savez quoi
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau